[Music]
there's no doubt that JK Rowling is a
brilliant writer but she isn't always a
great matchmaker stay tuned to find out
our favorite and least favorite Harry
Potter couples hey witches and wizards
if you want more videos like this one be
sure to subscribe now let's get to the
10 Harry Potter couples that we wish had
gotten together and the five that never
should have dated Harry Potter and Draco
Malfoy there's no two characters in the
entire series that have as much tension
as Harry Potter and Draco Malfoy from
the moment eleven-year-old Harry refuses
to be friends with Malfoy these two boys
become obsessed with each other Harry
pretty much always assumes that Malfoy
is up to no good and stalks him it
totally gets on Ron in Hermione's nerves
and draco spends way too much time
bothering Harry think about all the time
he spent making those Potter stinks
badges in goblets of fire that takes
some serious dedication we loved the
idea that their history would lead to
Draco's Redemption things may have
gotten complicated later on after all
Harry did nearly killed Draco and
half-blood Prince if they had just
admitted their love for each other with
Draco had ever become a Death Eater
there's no doubt that these two
characters would be one passionate ship
Ron and pansy we are total suckers for
the inter-house ships and we can
absolutely get behind a ronzi couple we
definitely don't get enough pansy
Parkinson in the books but we wish we
did Slytherin princess would have given
Ron a run for his money when it came to
sarcasm maybe the two could end up
together after they complain about Draco
and Harry's obsession with each other
that would be hilarious we aren't sure
if they are the OTP but pansy would have
made a much better first girlfriends for
Ron
then lavender did but we'll talk more
about that later we bet a relationship
with pansy would also make Ron way less
suspicious of slytherins in general this
is a fairly popular ship in the fanfic
world do you think these two should have
dated Sirius and Remus this is one of
the most popular fanfic ships Sirius
black and Remus Lupin were besties back
in their hogwarts days along with james
water and peter pettigrew in the Harry
Potter books Remus is totally able to
make the dramatic serious calm down and
serious is animagus Padfoot can totally
keep lupins in her werewolf in check
there's a ton of a use where these two
end up raising Harry after James and
Lily died we can't get enough of bad
idea they would be such an endearing
couple with reserved Lupin being the
responsible one and serious being the
cool parent and maybe Remus would have
been way happier if he and Sirius had
ended up together the poor way riff
deserved more happiness and so did
Sirius after his stints with Azkaban
Crabbe and Goyle if there are any two
characters that are basically the same
person its vincent crabbe
and Gregory Coyle the two sidekicks of
Draco Malfoy had so much in common
mostly they were both not that smart and
followed Malfoy blindly but there's no
way that they wouldn't have developed
some serious feelings always being
together their fathers were both Death
Eaters so chances are they hung out a
lot outside of school and let's not
forget how much time they spend together
on on bridges Inquisitor squad in the
books they even took Polyjuice potion
and became girls to guard the Room of
Requirement while Draco was in they're
up to no good if that's not a bonding
experience what is do you think Draco's
shipped his two best friends maybe
that's why he always had them doing
stuff for him
on second thought probably not Drake is
not exactly a matchmaker Dumbledore and
McGonagall okay we know that JK Rowling
has confirmed that Dumbledore was
actually in love with his best friend
Grindelwald
but Grindelwald was kind of evil and
Dumbledore wasn't the legendary wizard
and Hogwarts is great as headmaster
deserves someone way better than a
power-hungry tyrant and according to
Potter more McGonagall also had some
major heartbreak when she was young
Dumbledore was there to comfort her
these two could have totally fallen for
each other because they had such a great
friendship they are both brilliant and
brave Gryffindor's
they're both extremely powerful and they
both care about their students a lot in
fact they're both Masters of
Transfiguration
that's what Dumbledore taught before he
became
master we wonder if we'll see any of
their early friendship in the upcoming
fantastic beasts movies that would be
epic
Nevel and Luna
according to JK rowling Nevel ends up
marrying the Hufflepuff Hannah Abbott if
you like us this parent seems totally
random we are sure Hannah is a perfectly
nice girl but she's no Luna Lovegood
first of all Nevel and Luna are both
outcasts at Hogwarts Nevel never judges
Luna for her weird beliefs and they both
totally accept each other they both help
Harry fight in the Department of
mysteries so they're both very brave
they are absolutely perfect for each
other
while we could totally see why Luna ends
up with newts commander's grandson she
and Neville went through so much
together we love that the movies have
Neville declaring his love for Luna and
their ship name is love bottom which is
adorable Parvati in lavender these to
Gryffindor girls are absolutely made for
each other they start out as besties and
they become close really fast we can
only imagine that Parvati Patil was
feeling a little lost when she was
sorted into a different house than her
twin thank goodness she had lavender
brown as her roommate they aren't always
the most endearing characters and they
can be kind of mean to Hermione at times
we think that it makes total sense that
a love could have blossomed from this
deep friendship and Parvati didn't
really dig going to the Yule Ball with
Harry Potter although that was probably
Harry's fault
the two girls bonded over Divya nation
too we imagine that lavender and Parvati
would have gotten even closer when the
carros took over the school in Deathly
Hallows draco and Hermione
Hermione's shippers are one of the
fiercest group of fans and we do love us
some Draco Redemption storylines we know
that you're thinking Draco is awful -
Hermione all through school he called
her mud blood for crying out loud
the Draco was a kid who had listened to
his parents spout discrimination his
whole life we loved a use where Draco
realizes there's nothing wrong with
muggle-borns because he falls in love
with Hermione they're also both
incredibly smart and riff adores
Slytherin Parris give us life in the
fanfic world there are a bunch of egg
used where they both return for
eighth year at Hogwarts and fall in love
just wait till his father hears about
this he bet lucious would put himself in
Azkaban rather than accept a
relationship between Draco and Hermione
CMAs and Dean CMAs Finnegan and Dean's
Hampton are basically the male version
of lavender and Parvati they become best
friends pretty much immediately after
being sorted into Gryffindor they are
also both half-blood wizards these
Gryffindor's are inseparable they even
stayed friends when Simas thought harry
was lying about baltimore its return
isn't that the sign of true love they
can totally overlook each other's faults
unlike a lot of the characters there is
no official word on what happened to the
two of them following the Battle of
Hogwarts if this is not the perfect
setup for them to end up together then
we don't know what is they are often the
backgrounds couple in post Hogwarts
fanfic maybe one day JK Rowling will let
us know what really happened to them
Harry ends Hermione
we might get some flack for this pairing
but a lot of people consider Harry and
Hermione the OTP harmony shippers hate
that Hermione ends up with Ron and Harry
ends up with Ginny but these fans make a
lot of really great points
Hermione stands by Harry when Ron
doesn't several times throughout the
books and let's not forget how Ron
totally left them to hunt for Horcruxes
alone in Deathly Hallows Ron is really
insecure and Hermione isn't she deserves
someone with more confidence even JK
Rowling herself said that Hermione and
Ron only ended up together because she
wanted them to but that the way she
wrote it didn't really make sense
Hermione and Harry are always loyal to
each other and ron has the emotional
range of a teaspoon and that's it for
the 10 couples who should have dated now
let's see which couple should never have
ended up together Harry and Joe JK
Rowling is an amazing writer but
sometimes she throws couples together
who make no sense at all Harry and Cho
Chang is one of these okay we get that
Harry has a crush on Cho he's a team boy
after all crushes are bound to happen
even when you're supposed to be
defeating the Dark Lord
but their relationship feels so awkward
also Cho is still
the loss of her boyfriend Cedric in
order of the Phoenix we don't know if
the guy who was there when your
boyfriend was murdered is the best
option for a rebound it seems unlikely
that she would put up with an awkward
Harry for that long Cho just seems like
a really odd choice for Harry's first
love interest Ron and Marvin der Ron
Weasley and lavender Brown have arguably
the most annoying relationship in the
books
how could anyone forget one one this
relationship was doomed to fail lavender
crushed hard on Ron but Ron mostly
ignored her until her mine he called him
out on being emotionally immature about
kissing their whole relationship felt
like Ron was just trying to make
Hermione jealous which is super unfair
to both lavender and Hermione and
lavender just needed to chill also they
pretty much did nothing but make out all
the time and if we were Gryffindor's we
would have stayed far away from the
common room while these two are dating
we can only imagine how awkward everyone
around them felt we're glad Ron came to
his senses Tom Riddle sir and moreau
Gon's we only saw these two in
flashbacks but if there is any couple
who should never have paired up it's the
parents of Voldemort's first of all and
most importantly Merope gaunt had Tom
Riddle under a love spell that is just
not okay
consent is super important so we can't
exactly blame Tom sir for this really
bad relationship also Muro only fell in
love for the muggle because he was
handsome she had no idea if he would
make a good husband or not baroque has
some serious issues we know these two
had to be together so that we could have
the whole Baltimore storyline but their
whole marriage is super crunchy those
guns are really one messed-up family at
first we feel sorry for Moreau
but after what she did to Tom sir she's
just as bad as her father and brother
Remus and Tonks talk about a
relationship that came out of nowhere we
were just as shocked as Harry when we
found out that the two were interested
in each other we understand from a
literary point of view why they married
JK Rowling wanted there to be another
orphan of war just like Harry was but we
would have had an easier time believing
just about any other couple we find out
Tonks is interested in Remus
because they've been spending a lot of
time together in the order but we really
never see them interact and Remus has
some major concerns about being with
Tonks for one thing there is a huge age
difference and hello there is a war
going on we think just about any other
couple could have given us an orphan and
more time she interested me because
Hermione and Viktor Hermione and Viktor
Krum might be the weirdest couple in the
entire series there are a lot of red
flags in their relationship
first of all hermione tells Harry that
most of the time they spend together
Viktor just watches her study
that's creepy AF also Hermione is only
14 Viktor is a legal adult in the
Wizarding World and already plays
professional Quidditch that's also
pretty creepy that he's interested in
such a young girl and how did they even
start dating all of the sudden we find
out that she is Victor's date at the
Yule Ball when did that happen and
Hermione just doesn't seem like the type
to be interested in a guy who is just a
jock
we don't really see any sort of
intelligence that we know Hermione would
look for court glad that relationship
didn't continue who is your OTP in a
Harry Potter world don't be shy
let us know in the comments those are
the 10 couples in Harry Potter who
shouldn't have dated and the five that
should have stayed far away from each
other if you want more fun videos about
Harry Potter and other fandoms be sure
to subscribe
[Music]